There's been a lot of talk
lately about the one percent,
a group of privileged elites
who control a huge chunk
of the nation's wealth.
But America's
a very big country,
and way at the other end
of the economic spectrum
are the shoeless mountain folk
who are skeptical of plumbing
and worship the sun and moon
as powerful deities.
Well, an eye opening
new CNN poll hammers home
just how staggeringly uninformed
Americans can be.
Reporter Raffi Williams
noted on Twitter that,
when asked their opinions
on Democrats and Republicans,
one percent of Americans
had never heard of either party.
-(laughter) -Once percent.
One percent of Americans.
-U.S.A.!
-RHODES: Yeah.
ALL (chanting):
U.S.A.! U.S.A.! U.S.A.!
What is that?
What are things?
-What are things?
-(laughter)
-Shouting words.
-HARDWICK: Shouting things.
So, you do a little quick math,
and you go, "One percent.
Well, it's not that crazy,
one percent."
It's roughly 2.4 million people
who have never heard
of either political party!
But they know the whole
In-N-Out secret menu.
-HARDWICK: Oh, yeah,
they know... -Nail it.
-They know what animal style is.
-(applause and cheering)
Give me a double-double
and a double bill.
-(applause and cheering)
-They know protein style.
-America!
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
But it also means that there are
two and a half million Americans
being raised or held captive
in dirt-floored basements
right now,
who still somehow manage
to respond to political polls.
Do you see the irony?
'Cause they don't know
the parties,
but they'll respond
to the polls.
So, comedians,
what are the top election issues
for this other one percent?
-Kevin. -We got to get these
damn raccoons out of here!
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah, wherever they are,
just get the raccoons out.
-Flula.
-A constitutional amendment
that declares
that eating ain't cheating.
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-HARDWICK: Well... yes. -Nice.
Erica Rhodes.
I ain't got
no election problems.
-I get hard just fine.
-HARDWICK: Yeah, all right.